alors alors je alors je contrôlais les
billes être jeu contrôler les billets de
train bon ça peut être que toi ça
la contrôleuse sncf jacques bille et non
elle s'est plutôt j'étais les enfants
attrapent et l'accueil ici
pas
[Applaudissements]
je tirais des caddies le canada
tout court les
prisonniers qui verrait bien un bernard
tu as été après huissier tout s'annonce
assez bon bah oui c'est moi contrôleurs
de train j'étais contre la en fait mon
père était cheminot contrôleurs de route
à la sncf comme on disait et du coup
l'été c'est vrai que là il m'a pistonné
j'ai fait pendant deux mois juillet août
ça c'est extrêmement compliqué plus
compliqué que maintenant ils ont juste
un appareil de série contrôler
facilement même si leur métier toujours
difficile avec des heures impossibles
moi je le faisais et c'était beaucoup de
boulot mais c'était très bien payé je
reconnais dont je contredis les billets
mais il y en a qui n'avaient pas de
billets visitez pas prêt vicié d'accord
après oui si travailler et voilà c'est
un peu répressif
c'est tout l'inversé aujourd'hui c'est
très curieux quand même alors je
nettoyais le vomi sur les banques
ça c'est jean tour
pour ceux qui ont raté quelques épisodes
de la vie de guillaume genton faut
savoir que guillaume genton s'est fait
vomir dans la bouche pas paraît pas il y
avait aussi si vous l'avez dit cyril sur
la wii bah oui oui oui c'était à
l'époque mais c'était à l'époque sa
marque quand même hein
alors je vous quitte moi c'est pas moi
enfin pièces cachées sur pourquoi l'ipad
buts à l'appui non travaillées peut-être
comme barmaid dans une bonne réponse
mais il ya vraiment des gens qui
vomissent dans les boîtes de nuit sans
se soucier
comme hôte et oui je confirme et on m'a
demandé à ben oui owen dont je t'ai
donné ta promis j'ai dit non halal
terroriste est génial c'est qu'on voit
ce que les gens mangent et la veille
vous n'êtes jamais vous avez jamais vomi
en disposant jamais un peu trop bu
j'étais c'était moi je suis hémato fob
et c'est à dire que j'ai une phobie du
vomi si je vois du vomi ou champomy
robot me plains pas je deviens fou ah
bon et bien fou à quel point
je peux je peux tuer
alors alors il est jeune on ne tue pas
mais je mettrais phobie de ça mais ça y
est les crapauds donc
non non j'ai été magagi ça
clément je vais pas y aller comme ça moi
galilée
à l'edl
non jean daniel daniel nestor dako loi
nicholas colas oui peut-être il est le
nouveau l'argent que la folie non ce
n'est pas moi et là on va être nommé
mais en fait tu es et en fait c'est moi
on était déjà là tenu d'ailleurs
j'étais bagages en fait c'était geogeo
bagages jeux med je faisais des gares
donc je recevais des clients légers mk
avec dédé plein de la déjantée ligne
entre des clientes adecco qui me donner
leurs valises que je devais monter dans
le train pour
commencer au bagage après j'ai fait géo
j'ai fait jouer au tennis voilà après
j'ai fait la police sous marine on est
en retrait des gonzesses
alors je ne parle que vous le verrez non
j'étais là pour travailler au club mais
c'est pas là pour perdre les deux géants
vous êtes passé à gemma gros membres
alors si vous avez suivi les émissions
c'est pas la réputation chez moi cet
opus
est mon coeur vous avez vu sous la
douche et exhorte les membres parce que
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai des enfants attrapent et
l'économie crée donc
j'essaie de me témoigner
[Rires]
sur un manège en fait j'ai quand j'étais
gamine j'allais dans ce manège et après
j'ai travaillé et donc je prenais les
tickets géante chez auto mais leur
expliquer
alors ça signifie
pas que vous aviez non mais c'est vrai à
les petits bolides ont chopé académique
m
à
je remarque est en fait dès l'enfance
vous habiller comme une vieille
c'est non mais c'est incroyable
longtemps c'était pas la même made by
mais là c'était un choix de modèles
et marques bordeaux c'est incroyable
parce qu ils allaient souvent par des
moyens accrus bordeaux l'arrêt web
arrière regarder on va brasser revanche
avancé on va avancer alors le tableau
des métiers alors je louais des vhs
alors pour ceux qui nous regardent et
paie à la place elle avait versé sur des
cassettes
cd
s'arracher salivaire métaux scop hommes
étaient des casseurs ces gens sérieux à
la pointe maintenant
il est trop jeune trop jeune c'est la
gueule maintenant il passait la bague
ali alors c'est aux mélodies ou panique
ans et je suis partie cost et éric
fatoux lescoules magali pacetti alors
choisir unique chez ses pairs dit oui
magali magail ah oui et vous vous levez
des vhs alors c'était quoi tend à ces
chocs ou cet été
alors chabiba il ya de trop mais et
quand tu étais petit budget j'habitais à
se protéger bien des amoureux ce que
c'est mal à côté des impôts bref et en
fait j'étais bateau loué le week-end ça
me faisais mes sous pour acheter mes
petits trucs en fait émond est en fait
je louais des cassettes vidéo le plus
gênant c'est quand ils viennent louer
des cas c'est effectivement x non mais
c'est un peu gêné ci avait 14 ans aa et
comment on conseille alors
il ya une loi qui vous laisse travailler
quelques heures peut tout petits à
l'époque un jeu pas sur paris mais
pendant que je travaillais je t'ai
déclaré tous et j'imagine la scène je
vais vous prendre ton de toi que je
marque
[Applaudissements]
alors changé
déjà déjà avec cyril c'est vous vous
lâchez
vraiment là alors là c'est n'importe
quoi
on est en chaussant toujours ce qu'il a
vraiment aller j'étais cuit et
intelligente et défaire les coffres à
delphine de l'hernie cov non non alors
[Musique]
c'est qui delphine clément gamin c'était
mon fils à longueuil les gens tout le
temps vous avec votre avec votre voix
vous êtes vous et vous emmener des gens
téléphonent me parlez pas de la voir
parce que je ne les ai saisies en guinée
va pouvoir
non mais en fait j'étais à la
[Rires]
dgt la direction départementale des
territoires et vous voulez une passe et
qu'il faut ménager tout prix ça marche
pas il est tout près c'est depuis qu'il
a gueulé ça fait des années maintenant
j'étais à la direction départementale
des territoires et je devais répondre au
téléphone mais ça me faisait tellement
riche que j'ai envoyé péter tout le
monde c'est surtout qu'on comprenait pas
tout
et au bout de 24 heures ils m'ont dit
bon c'est bon vatanen un bureau tu fais
rien de moi tu es payé à rien [ __ ] ils
m'ont laissé pas d'impôt offert aux fans
appelle moi très bien là j'avais je vais
galérer pendant toute l'émission
sont peu toi un peu de miel pour ça va
être compliqué alors je payais des
patates cuites au sénat par de fines ça
s'est fait en quoi elle pas beau oui oui
je sais vous j'avais 16 ans j'étais
agent communal pendant l'été à chaque
fois et donc il fallait pas sous le
cagnard peindre les passages piétons
pour que ça sèche plus vite qu'un des
volets des écoles donné à voir leur
lente et tout et tout et après j'ai
arrêté ça et après je faisais
surveillante quand j'étais en en second
des surveillantes pionne pour les petits
enfants les poules mc cain est
surveillant d'une grande classe
et oreillers
j'étais là j'étais là chef des
surveillantes savez vous devez de vous
devez être un peu méchant non j'étais
j'étais hyper blue byte non j'arrivais à
j'arrivais à vraiment bien à tenir les
enfants et c'était très bien donc quand
le directeur n'était pas là quand mes
autres potes et en fait il est sûre il
est des autres classes quand ils
n'arrivaient pas surveiller quand le
directeur n'est pas là il faisait
attention sinon j'appelle delphine
déjà l'été comme ça donc ça chahutait y
mange passé dans le noir je regardais
déjà très grande comme comme comme
maintenant non mais j'avais l'autorité
naturelle
et les gens le lapon qu'ils ont quand il
parle quand même si
je travaillais comme pompier
alors les amis grand pascal la gabarre
avant été repérés d'ailleurs sur la
plage de croix de biarritz non saint
jean
et jean pascal état est un vrai
sauveteurs en mer et il a été décoré
décoré par michèle alliot-marie
puisqu'il à sauver 3 vies
je n'ai jamais jamais maintenu vas-y
mais j'avais très bien passé bien aimé
dire les frais très bien sûr
non mais ça aussi non je n'ai pas tourné
espèce de salon
j'étais comme ça voilà voyez comme ça
est ce que ça vous plaît regardez-moi
sauveteurs
ça va ça va très bien donc oui j'ai
sauvé des vies et on n'a pas la musique
de alerte à malibu discale qui n'est pas
venu avec talent par hasard et si
j'étais bien que mal en ce qu'est ce que
c'est je le déshabille non non non mais
là mais je vais demander une bassine
d'eau fera des glaces en cours
d'échangés de placement allez allez
allez allez votre lot à 6 mg a prévalu
j'ai gardé à valcourt
[Applaudissements]
ah non
on
attendra quand on over on va faire un
sauvetage avec le
medialab
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
j'arrive
ici madame madame attendez je me sens ne
respecte pas elle ne respecte pas les
populations
[Applaudissements]
à sa baguette
à bouffer elle revient elle revient sans
madame ça va
les voiliers j'ai fait ça
merci au cours simon
[Applaudissements]
allez
alors je tire et que dit de le faire ça
et c où tu sais où vous bossez albert a
mal au bout
s'est passé comme dans les cieux indique
dollars
elle et les caddies des golfeurs c'est
marqué sur fond je vous ai 18 trous
c'est son volant ouais samba lolf de
fourqueux ses longues jambes alors très
bon
car sur 18 trous au bloc d'infos que ça
fait beaucoup quand tu avais
compris la vague allez allez et donc je
me suis déguisé en masse comme ça c'est
une vanne bon c'est vrai mais vous
déguiser en voit pas marcher à
strasbourg j'étais déguisé en poulet
enrich de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
haggis et les clients pour leur vendre
des aiguillettes des nuggets saint
sébastien est un micro moi je parlais et
vous vous disiez j'ai bienvenue rayon
moyen de votre magasin super u je suis
le gentil poulet si tu es belle
[Applaudissements]
la cegos